they took the security forces by
surprise
the protest scheduled for late afternoon
began five hours early
at the entrance to the military base
demonstrators tried to force their way
reinforcements were quickly called in
and a confrontation with French troops
averted
but the demonstrators say they won't
leave
all military buses want to fight
tomorrow with our country all military
buses in our country we don't want it
because more than 13 years all
terrorism is here they don't take care
to fight the tourism
despite a heavy downpour thousands
continue to arrive perched on top of
homes
others of Street Glam posts or anywhere
they can
blaring their trumpets
this demonstration is the largest since
supporters of the cool turn their
attention on the military base near the
airport air in the capital near me
inside there is an estimated 1500 French
soldiers the demonstrators want them out
France says it's ambassador to Tunisia
and troops are staying relations between
Niger and its former colonial power have
deteriorated since the coup I welcome
if this crisis isn't handled
diplomatically there's the risk of
clashes between the two sides for the
Junta it's important to make the French
Ambassador leave otherwise it'll look
weak in the eyes of its supporters the
government in France is looking to
provoke the Junta by questioning its
legitimacy
having been forced out of former
colonies Malian Burkina Faso analysts
say France may not leave Niger without a
scene
and the Junta here will do all it can to
ensure the French leave at least to save
face or supporters who stood by it Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera nyame
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera